[Applause]
[Music]
located in a narrow water inlet
separates Europe and Asia Istanbul is a
city rooted in the most influential
corners of history few cities can boast
of having a past like there's a city
once known as Byzantium then
constantinople istanbul was once the
capital of three great empires the Roman
Empire of the East the Byzantine Empire
and the Ottoman Empire places like San
Sofia the Blue Mosque and the Grand
Bazaar are legacies from that era hold
on a second because all of that is well
it's the past
[Music]
nowadays Istanbul is a lively city that
hosts more than 15 million inhabitants
it's the largest city in all of Europe
and it's also an important economic
Enclave one out of every three dollars
of turkey's gdp is generated here and
even the barely hosts 1/5 of the
country's entire population the Turkish
government gets about half of all its
tax revenue from Istanbul so we're
talking about he's true economic engine
here
[Music]
it's a growing financial logistics
commercial and of course a touristic hub
Istanbul attracts thirteen point four
million foreign visitors in 2018 however
in recent years Istanbul has begun to be
well known for a different kind of
tourism a very very special kind of
tourism and it is as controversial as it
is special so maybe you've heard of
medical tourism a high-flying tour every
year hundreds of millions of people
travel abroad to experience a new
culture and enjoy the Sun the beach the
mountains or the famous art and
architecture however another type of
unconventional but highly coveted
tourism this recently gains popularity
and that's medical tourism that is
travelling to another country to visit
its monuments its beaches and in passing
just also fix anything that they may
need fixed they usually come for three
days we offer them shopping or skiing
tours they get well and have a short
vacation
khasim devran Oulu the medical head of
dunya clothes group and i can already
tell you that for many governments
starting with turkeys this is a priority
now of course at this point we need to
answer to questions that many of you
might be asking the first is why go to
another country in search of medical
treatments well this has three very
clear answers the first is the price of
course if you have a medical procedure
that isn't covered by your health
insurance price matters a great deal for
example some interventions and
treatments so much cheaper in Istanbul
than they are in the United States and
when I say much cheaper I mean much
cheaper they can be 50 60 70 even 80
percent cheaper
the second reason has to do with waiting
lists yeah you may be covered by your
health insurance or social security but
what about waiting lists in public
health systems such as those found in
Spain or the United Kingdom it's very
common to have waiting lists which can
be really quite long this of course
means that you have to wait a long time
for your turn but of course what happens
if you can't or you don't want to wait
then you need to find something on your
own and in that scenario the big
international medical centers don't
really have waiting lists soft they're
much shorter waiting time for a knee
surgery in a western country is 18
months but is only two weeks at the most
in Turkey every day a codon chairman of
the Istanbul International Health
Tourism Association check out how the
number of British medical tourists has
grown and the third reason is quality
yeah you had that right
when a place specializes in a particular
treatment and as many patients it tends
to be better you probably all know about
Houston Texas Medical Center which
serves about 10 million patients every
year and is one of the leading medical
centers on the planet in the end these
places have so many patients and so many
resources that not only are they very
good at their job they can also become
engines of medical research and
innovation but we said that we had two
questions we already answered one so
well what's the second the other
question is why exactly is this such an
important activity for a country why
would a government want to promote this
type of activity why would it want to
become an international healthcare
center what does it bring to a country
[Music]
well think about it along with the
traditional jobs that tourism creates
for example in the hotel industry
waiters cooks etc medical tourism helps
create a lot of highly qualified and
well-paid jobs doctors surgeons nurses
laboratory personnel medical device
suppliers etc I believe the city
hospitals will become the focal points
of health tourism we are setting up
special units in the city hospitals to
specifically serve foreign patients
Turkish Health Minister Farah Tanuja due
to the billing level since the type of
activity generated medical tourism is
like the Rolex of tourism and on top of
that it doesn't have the problem of
seasonality unlike holiday tourism which
tends to concentrate with interest a few
months usually during the summer and
it's precisely these reasons that have
prompted the Turkish government to place
great hope in medical tourism a lot of
hope and a lot of money in the form of
incentives fewer taxes financing aid etc
and you know what in a way it does make
a lot of sense
allow me to explain if turkey is already
a touristic power it has hotels
infrastructure all kinds of services a
lot of cultural attractions and places
like Istanbul they're only two or three
hours away by plane from the main cities
of Europe and the yeast so why not take
advantage well guys sir was says so it
was done
turkey attracted nearly 1 million health
tourists in 2018 industry official says
[Music]
and as I mentioned this type of tourism
leaves much more money in a country's
pockets than regular holiday tourism in
2018 medical tourists left more than two
billion dollars in Turkey
thus turkey is already the third largest
market in the world in terms of medical
and health tourism it stands only behind
the United States and South Korea so
medical tourism in Turkey is multiplied
by more than ten in the last decade just
in 2008 alone they welcomed 75,000
people in other words the industry is
skyrocketing Turkey's medical tourism
industry boosts visitor numbers when
turkey's traditional tourism industry
dried up the country turned to its
medical sector to attract a new wave of
visitors business destinations of course
all of this is just the beginning of
what the government expects the goal is
to generate five times as much income
from medical tourism by 2023 greatly
exceeding the ten billion dollar barrier
and some within the government and the
private sector are even more ambitious
their goal is 20 billion dollars it's a
huge business and it also gives the
country a large foreign currency inflow
dental care cosmetic surgery fertility
treatment cardiovascular interventions
transplants oncological treatments
turkey and particularly Istanbul wants
to become a world leader in
international medical tourism and in one
way or another this will be very good
for all of us why listen up the cluster
assemble is quickly becoming the world
leader in several medical specialities
from ophthalmology to knee care and hair
transplants in some of these fields it's
already number one on the entire planet
and it's that way because of price and
because of innovation yeah you heard
that right
it has to do with a logical and well
known market process called cluster
creation allow me to explain this
happens when a site specializes in an
activity and many competitors engage in
the same activity this causes everything
in the area to somehow begin to revolve
around that industry the number of
suppliers that compete with each other
multiplies public administrations begin
to facilitate things for this
increasingly influential industry
universities work with these companies
etc
this creates a more dynamic ecosystem
and it multiplies its innovation
capacity in other words so to speak
Istanbul is becoming the Silicon Valley
of cataracts and hair transplants for
whoever might want them all this might
sound like a bit of a joke but it really
isn't the city of Basra is already has
hundreds of clinics that specialize in
these types of activity in many cases
we're talking about very new clinics
with very advanced treatments and it's
estimated that by 2025 these types of
interventions will move tens and tens of
billions of dollars worldwide anyway I
think we can now understand news like
this a bit better the global medical
tourism market size is expected to reach
one hundred and seventy nine point six
billion dollars by 2026 registering a
twenty one point nine percent kegger
during the forecast period so I really
hope you've enjoyed this video if you
did please do hit that like button and
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos also don't forget to check out
our friends at the ricans intermedia
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine also this
channels possible because of patreon
ends our patrons on that platform please
do consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent
political coverage as always I'll see
you in the next video
[Music]
you